[Music]
right um well in texas um for breakfast
brunch or even lunch or even dinner
trust me steak and eggs
but this is steak and eggs with a twist
because i'm using the most amazing
bone in ribeye so when i say steak i'm
talking about steak of the highest order
and we know the texas longhorns have to
be the best
cattle anywhere in america amazing we'll
start off with a dry rub
okay so we lightly salt both sides
and then we get this beautiful rub now
i've got a teaspoon of coffee
and so chili paprika and smoked paprika
in there
we sit that in there and we just
literally push that down
in take off the cooling wire for now
and push that down and what i'm trying
to do now is just flatten
that beautiful steak you can see with
the heat
how quick it's melting now the secret
there
is i've got all that flavor pressed in
the steak's been out for a good 10-15
minutes so it's got nice and warm
so the fat started to release so it
takes on all that incredible
seasoning so we are ready for the pan
now
in the pan piping hot into a skillet
touch of olive oil and then watch this
baby go
look at that i mean that is even the
same shape as
the texas county here we go
beautiful i'm gonna get some
onions in there as well but
i actually want to cook the onions okay
at the same time
big thick slices of onions
all in at the same time okay open them
up
and get them in there
beautiful next to that
garlic so garlic literally down
and just slightly smashed garlic goes in
i want to fry those onions get that baby
working
don't turn that steak until you're ready
okay really important
don't turn
her too early take your time let the fat
render
and look you've got a beautiful ancho
chili smoked paprika flavor coming out
those onions are frying beautifully
now i'm going to hit it with some butter
at the top of the pan
start caramelizing those onions
beautiful
that's so good it's so tempting to turn
that steak
we do not turn that really important you
don't turn it now get ready i'm gonna
get my eggs
on chop my scallions and i want a nice
sort of
lift to the eggs that is beautiful right
there
in she goes now lightly season them
and now we're ready for the magic i'm
going to turn that steak very very very
very quickly
up the top look at that
oh boy oh my god right the eggs
in goes the oil always crack
on a beautiful flat surface
and literally drop that egg in there
be useful for my eggs a touch of butter
and she goes touch the seasoning now
and then just a touch of the smoked
beautiful seasoning and then look what
i'm gonna do
i've got the greens of the scallions
gonna be cooked with the eggs okay
really important because it's gonna
slide right out there
and then from there i'm gonna put the
tips on the eggs and then the base
goes in to sweeten up those onions look
at that
and then literally before i take that
steak out got some cilantro
and that gets chopped really nice
some of my eggs gently done
and the rest goes in over the steak
now look at those onions look what's
happened to that steak
it is suited and booted
that is so beautiful eggs go on to
finish off
nice and gently now before that steak
comes out
okay i want to roll that over think of
the spice to the heat the coffee the
chili
the salt we'll slice that
down and then look
hit that with the lime juice
over there oh boy
was beautiful now watch
because this we don't want to miss any
of the magic
look at this this comes out
that goes on there
oh my god
those eggs are beautiful
now when we come to plate this what you
do now is you peel back
those onions just peel them back
okay place onto the center
that's all those beautiful onions that
we fried off
with that ribeye look at that oh my god
the smell of the onions
look where that bone is and i'm gonna
just take this beautiful eye
off save that bit for later but look at
that
and that is pink that's peppa pig
himself
and then beautifully just come down
don't go too mad
never slice a rib eye thin ever
lift that up one inch thickness
on you lay that over
and then you just open that up there
open open open
a light season in between
just hit it with a touch of salt in
there a touch of pepper
and all you do now get those delicious
eggs
and you get a spoon and the secret here
now is to slide those eggs
texan style over the meat
beautiful the second one
and there you have it a stunning
beautiful
rib eye fried eggs texan style
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch on catch up
on disney plus